well the economy is much improved for
blue-collar workers under president
Trump's leadership but another group
that continues to do astonishingly well
are employees of the federal government
according to a new report by the
watchdog group open the books the
federal government pays its workers 1
million dollars per minute 66 million
dollars per hour and 524 million dollars
per day great paycheck and at 78 federal
government agencies the average employee
compensation exceeded $100,000 in 2016
all of that is being paid for with your
tax dollars so for more let's bring in
from Chicago the CEO and founder of
opened the books Adam and Jeff and Jeff
ski right ngf ski is that your name all
right so let's go through these numbers
one more time astonishing by the minute
how much we're paying federal employees
for their time
well federal employees the bureaucracy
is paid a million dollars a minute and
you're exactly right it's a half billion
dollars a day what we also found would
we not only open those books but we
audit them our team of auditors found
that there are 30,000 federal
bureaucrats that out earn every governor
of the 50 states at $190,000 a year
that's their salary we also found that
if you're a highly compensated federal
bureaucrat and we define that as over
two hundred thousand dollars a year of
salary and bonus that the number of
federal employees has increased over the
course the last six years by one hundred
and sixty five percent so what about
that the president has been criticized
for not filling all the positions in the
federal government can the federal
government function without filling
these positions and would it actually
make it more beneficial for taxpayers so
the president has led on this with his
own payroll at the White House he's
running a leaner payroll than at the
same point as during the Obama
administration
he's down a hundred positions and we
forecast that would save taxpayers 20
million dollars over the course of his
four years the first lady is also
leading on this she has a payroll of
five employees versus 24 employees as
former first lady Michelle Obama had but
here's the point Katie everybody
watching the program
here tonight needs to come to open the
books calm we have met the two million
federal bureaucrats by zip code so
everyone can see in their own zip code a
small piece of the swap a small piece of
the federal bureaucracy all of us need
to give it oversight and when we give
that oversight there has to be
transparency impact we have to ask our
member of Congress what they are doing
to squeeze out the bloat in the Federal
Bureau so it's not just inside the
beltway bleed the stuff out into the
rest of the country as well you talk
about oversight and transparency the
numbers on bonuses are absolutely
incredible three hundred and thirty
thousand bonuses for three hundred and
fifty-one million dollars total federal
bonuses 1.5 billion dollars and none of
that is disclosed essentially or is very
small portion right only one-third of
the total bonuses are actually disclosed
and this is a real problem it's a
transparency problem because the union's
the federal unions negotiated into their
contract that the performance bonuses
that's 1.1 billion dollars worth of
performance bonuses aren't disclosed
there aren't disclosed to we the people
on who gets what in terms of performance
bonus and we showed that small federal
agencies there's an agency out in San
Francisco California
they only employ 300 people but they
three out of the four largest bonuses
last year they had three of them these
are not rocket scientists they're not
curing cancer they're a land management
organization and the top bonus in the
entire federal system went to their
human resource manager it was one
hundred and forty-one thousand dollars
how is that I mean how is it that this
is negotiated at such a high rate as we
said at the beginning of the segment
many of these bureaucrats are being paid
as much or more than elected senators I
mean how does that process work and how
do they get to those numbers well it's
not only the compensation on salary and
bonuses but it's also other perquisite
s-- like paid time off so if you if
you're a federal bureaucrat and if you
hit your three-year anniversary you
stand in line to get eight and a half
weeks of paid time off it's ten holidays
thirteen sick days 20 vacation days 43
days a year of paid time off that's a
perk that costs taxpayers every single
year twenty two billion dollars sounds
like Europe you know european-style
living and working to me inside the
beltway and outside as you pointed out
the the 2018 elections are coming up
Republicans have been running for years
on cutting spending spending cuts are
always very difficult but if you could
advise politicians and congressmen on
Capitol Hill who are worried about this
issue what would you say to them in
terms of how to make sure that taxpayer
dollars aren't being abused in this way
to cuts for two billion dollars really
quickly and the bonus program it's one
point five billion dollars and then
Katie and this is bipartisan federal PR
officers there's 3,500 of them the line
item in the budget every single year is
a half a billion dollars on salary and
total cost and that should be cut as
well okay well Adam thank you so much
for your expertise we have a lot of work
to do